alors maintenant jacques on va jouer à
un jeu idiot
comme d'habitude toute façon je vais te
donner des noms de gens comme ça un peu
comme le tir au pigeon d'argile je vais
les jeter en l'air et tu vas me dire ce
que tu en penses
zhu à ski par exemple bien t'en pense
que du bien ça va bien bien vis-à-vis de
moi bien vis-à-vis de toi bien très bien
très bien bah oui ça fait faire le film
quitte à lancer et suis quitte à
relancer donc avec ado bien plein bon
bin en plein second tremplin godard bien
bien jolie revient tout le temps comme
ça bah écoute
j'aime bien codeurs moi aussi en moins
claude sautet assez la famille dray je
ne peux que l'acier
chez drucker comme un monstre de rigueur
parce que - les questions était idiote
et de ville toute façon je peux tu
tournes avec lui en ce moment j'ai pas
là t'as pas le choix ça y est super je
laime ouais je vais dicter aux idiots
mathilda may on m'avait prévenu qu'elle
avait une poitrine gigantesque elle
prend l'avion
et je n'ai pas de tous âges y connait
pas grand chose mais comme tu le sais
j'ai trouvé ça j'ai trouvé tout à fait
normal et que c'est une très bonne
comédienne patrick bruel dans le même
film qui s'appelle pour le moment sweet
art mais il s'appelle l'inspecteur vad
dans le film est bien bien
antoine je mets à fleurs antoine il a
bien fait de faire de la voile ouais
voilà à peine on y vient doucement ouais
françoise hardy
quoi ben oui non bien pas bien
jacques lanzmann donc sachez revue way
to l'artois oui tu leur vie dans 45
tours il marche tout seul
gainsbourg
bah écoutes je crois que là il est
absent pour un peu oui langue etc le
c'est quand même le parrain but vous
étiez très lié on a fait je vais pas
faire le genre sanglots c'était moi
c'était un ami oui face est un ami
c'est un des rares d'ailleurs deux par
rapport à ce métier claude françois tu
es là connue mais je n'ai connu
maquiller je n'ai pas reconnu
démaquiller
est ce qu'un jour il a débarqué en force
mais j ai demandé qu'est ce que c'était
que ce monsieur c'est n8
c7 bras
1-2 oui mais lui c'est un pote on s'est
connus on devait avoir passé l'âge de 14
ans ou 13 ans à la trinité la grande
époque midi-minuit la trinité elle était
pareil il va pas changer
lui profondément non mais autour oui
puisque quand c'est mad max et norman
mac en hippie enfin il faillit suivi des
trucs mais c'est un des rares qui même
s'ils se met au goût du jour il est
toujours là jeunesse est un des rares
qui est une présence
et celle à celle à quoi est-ce que tu as
connu c'est là c'est pareil j'ai voulu
diminuer la caméra explore le temps elle
est allée du dîner c'est huawei elle
adore le saucisson en parlant de ceux ci
sont tu trouves pas à scandaleux les
rumeurs pour couru sur son compte
sheila est un homme avait laissé ça
c'était l'époque qu'on se faisait pas
opéré oui maintenant il ya plus de
rumeurs les pointures de ne rien rater
le leader des tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu